- The nominees for Best
Performance by an Actress
in a Leading Role in a
Play, Lauren Ridloff,
Children of a Lesser God.
(applause) (gentle, ambient music)
- The first time that I was introduced
to Children of a Lesser
God was when I was eight.
The movie came out and my parents decided
to take me to see the movie even though
they knew it was for adults.
It had a huge impact on me to see
another deaf adult on the big screen.
I never once thought
that I would be Sarah.
First of all, I'm a woman of color,
and I just assumed that it was a given
that Sarah was going to be white.
(gentle, ambient music)
I was a school teacher,
so I taught kindergarten
and first grade in public education.
Every day I had to read
aloud with my students,
and that always involves acting in a way.
And a tough audience, children.
And then I left to raise my own two boys.
Kenny was presented with the possibility
of doing a revival of
Children of a Lesser God,
and he decided that he wanted
to meet a person who was deaf first.
So he contacted me.
We set up a time to meet.
Then we set up a plan to meet once a week
for a year and we would
talk about deaf culture,
I would teach him some signs...
So, after a year of meeting,
and I was his teacher
and he was my student,
he then asked me to be a participant
in the first reading with Joshua Jackson.
After that reading was over,
he pulled me aside and said,
"If this goes all the way,
are you willing to go all the way?"
And my answer is pretty clear.
And working with Joshua Jackson
made the whole process so easy.
He's such a veteran.
He's been in this industry for so long.
This story holds such a special place
for the deaf community. It opened doors
to Broadway back when
it first was performed.
We definitely have a long way to go
regarding inclusivity in this business.
When you hear the word
inclusion in this industry,
it tends to focus on
color and I think we need
to broaden that to people with
different abilities as well.
It makes us better people.
Once your eyes are opened and
you're exposed to differences,
different ways of living, different ideas,
you're feelings grow.
And once you're exposed
to something like that,
you can't go back, you
can only move forward.
So I think it's really
important to meet people,
to hear their stories, especially
if their stories are not like yours.
Because when you do, you find
that universal connection.
(inspiring instrumental music)